Oh, welcome everybody to another zoom call reminder to go ahead and chat in your questions. Well, like I one two three four five that came in.
So you think of something? How was the time to chat it in?
This is the day the Lord has made. Let us rejoice and be glad in it. We all lead that reminder. Maybe you don't. Maybe it's just me.
Be that reminder every day. What difficulties come to rejoice and know that God has control of my outcomes and I can trust in him in everything.
Reminder to look at the announcements. This is an old screenshot, but there's a new announcement. So the new announcement is for members for full members you guys.
I've reduced the cost of the regular office visits. So starting today, the office visits for members are now $85 instead of $135.
So that's a good thing. I did put that in the announcements and you'll see it. If you guys self-schedule on the members homepage, it'll be that new pricing.
So work your calling does make a difference, but so it's already set in the calendar self-schedule program as well.
All right, let's get to your questions. First question came in. How many times per day can I run my day programs? Well, you could run your day programs over and over and over and over throughout the day.
So there isn't a limit to running your day programs. The only thing that I would say is if you are going to be fairly non-ambulatory and you're going to be sitting and reading for a considerable length of time.
Let's say eight hours, just run your night program against it or not hit, you know, open up a computer and hit run because your day programs are only an hour to two hours long.
So then just run your night program if you're going to be sitting there for a long time.
So, but let's say you got two hours here and other two hours later on and another two hours tonight before you go to bed, then go ahead and run your day programs three times.
I've always said you could explore other programs. If you have other cold morbidities, you know, you might have an infection or you might have, you know, you feel like cold is coming on or something like that. Go ahead and run those programs at your will.
Especially if your cancer is, you know, doing well, but if your cancer is, you know, not in the doing well phase and it is very active that I would spend the majority of my time running cancer programs.
When I was in the throws of my cancer, I was only running my cancer programs and I was running at, you know, at night.
Actually, as soon as I got home, I was so, you know, I just, I was still going to work, but I was basically working from my desk like I'm sitting right now the entire day.
So I was running my right at the office. I had a wife running and I ran that the whole day that I went home and when I was really, you know, I wasn't doing anything.
I was going home and sitting in my chair and turned down the right, but I was running the right and then when I went to bed, I turned it out.
So I was literally running it almost 24-7 when I was in the throws. I mean, obviously I wasn't 24-7 because I was, you know, living, you know, up and doing stuff.
But every time I was sitting doing nothing, which when I was really sick, it was a lot of time when I was sitting doing a whole little lot of nothing.
I was running the right. So, you know, when you're in the throws of the cancer, the more right time you can get the better chance you have at survival.
So I really believe that it was the action of the right machine that put me in the state of remission that I'm in right now.
So don't not run your right when you are sitting.
Now, I do want you to be living it up and doing things and living your life.
But if you are exhausted, you have to sit down and you're going to rest and I got to, I'll go read a book or I'm going to read my Bible, then turn out of the right and be doing you running the right.
Okay, this next question, this person sent in this question and they call me back is that I follow the answer to my questions. You don't have to put it in, but I thought it was a good question to put in because this is really a hot topic.
In Instagram, I personally deleted my Instagram. We have our business Instagram account. So if you're following us, you're still seeing our Instagram posts that my daughter is posting on there for me, but I by personal Instagram.
What I got this cold a few weeks ago, I was really praying and convicted by the Holy Spirit to not be looking at Instagram anymore.
I deleted Instagram and Facebook off my phone and I'm just going to just spending my time reading my Bible and listening to my Bible on tape when I have free time.
That's just what the Holy Spirit has led me to do. But you know, if you listen to anything I've said in the last year and a half that I have a really hard time with all these influencers on Instagram, selling things.
Because 90% of what they're selling a 10% of what they're selling they might be right on what they're saying and I agree with them. But 90% of the time I'm like, oh my gosh, are you kidding.
It's just ridiculous and I even though I do think red light therapy has benefits. I think it's 100% oversold by influencers who are trying to sell red light therapy devices.
So red light therapy is a frequency of red light that is one frequency and it isn't powerful enough as far as amp output and any red light therapy device to go any farther than the first layer of dermis of your skin.
Now that being said, it can have benefits to helping you know heal the skin. It can have benefits to helping heal, you know, an infection or something on the skin.
So I'm not saying there isn't a use for it. I'm just saying that the influencers that are selling are selling are making claims that cannot be backed by science.
And you know, if they were a practitioner like me with a clinic, they would have the FDA after them and they would have you know the state boards after them for making claims that can't be backed by science.
But it seems like as an influencer on Instagram and Facebook, they could say anything they want to say and that bothers me a lot. I think that hurts the general public a lot and I think it hurts alternative care a lot because people get confused.
Now that being said, let me get to the question. I've seen a lot of interesting information on the use of red light therapy for healing and other uses such as cancer.
I have an older LED technologies, LLC, the PL unit I purchased years ago and would consider using it to assist in wood healing where the tumor is.
So if you have an external wood and again, you're you're not expecting this red light therapy to go any deeper than a millimeter and by all means, yes, I think you could use it.
I don't think there's any negatives to it.
So continue with the question. I've seen both positive and negative opinions regarding the effects on a tumor.
Would this be advantageous to getting direct as getting direct sunlight in warmer weather months, thanks in advance for your insight.
I think getting direct sunlight would probably be better, but I think during the winter, if you have a unit, there's nothing wrong with using it.
Probably a lot of you that are listening to me have a red light therapy and you're using it and you might feel like it's helped you by all means.
I have no trouble using it. I have trouble with the claims that are being made about it trying to sell devices. That's my struggle with it.
That's my struggle with a lot of the different therapies and or supplements that are being touted on the internet by influencers.
It's the claims that are being made that can influence people in I think the wrong way.
Okay, next question.
What if my cancer metastasizes to my spine? Do I need an update on my life frequencies?
So remember, no, if your cancer metastasizes, it's still cancer.
So let's say I have a breast cancer and now I found out it's metastasized to my thoracic vertebrae.
Oh my gosh, do I need a bone cancer programmed out? No, you don't.
It's still breast cancer in the bone.
So your original primary cancer metastasizes to another organ. It still sells from that original cancer.
So if I have prostate cancer and it metastasizes to my liver, it's not liver cancer now.
It's still prostate cancer in my liver. So those same frequencies will be helpful.
So is there ever a reason why I should update my cancer program?
Maybe, but not one that I can really think of.
There I do have some people that have a second cancer, a second primary cancer that they found out.
They had abdominal cancer, colon cancer that they found out.
They had some spots on their lung that were biopsy and it was a primary lung cancer.
So that's not a great news. You got two completely different cancers.
That's a reason to update your frequencies because I have to put 50% of the night in colon cancer and 50% of the night in lung cancer.
Because that's a total, those are different frequencies. So that would be a reason.
But if I have a primary cancer that metastasizes the bone, it's going to be the same frequencies.
So it's always good to ask the question.
So if you have that question on your cheek swab test, check for, is there any new frequencies?
There have been over the year. So I would update your program.
So I'll let you know if we need to do that when you send in your cheek swab test.
That's question. If I haven't been so good at taking my supplements for a few months,
should I just get back on them or should I do another cheek swab test?
Probably do it. I mean, if you still have the supplements,
let's say you haven't taken them for three months because you've been feeling really good and you've really fallen off the wagon.
And then I got this, did you feel convicted for some reason?
Or you get a symptom that reminds you that, you know, I can't ignore this and you decide to get back on the wagon.
If you still have the supplements, start taking them right away.
But it would probably be wise to do another cheek swab test because things could change if you haven't been on them for three months.
So if you had supplements, get right back on them again, but send in a cheek swab and we'll check and tweak your protocol.
And, you know, we also want to be cognizant of, did you stop taking them because you just were tired of taking supplements or you stopped taking them because you're just feeling great.
You just, you're not really good at the discipline of taking supplements like me.
There's reasons why we stopped doing things. So we want to know that too.
So it's like, I stopped taking them because I just can't keep, I just can't.
Well, we'll try to, you know, get the most important ones so you're at a more minimal program, but that you can stay on.
You know, so we want you to be on the things that are going to be the most cancer killing that that are going to be the best for you that you are that you can stay on.
No, since putting together the perfect program, somebody and they just won't do it.
I've done that over the years. I've had people that have done the cheek swab test,
paid for our whole program, started with us, said to the regimen and they never even bought anything. They never did anything.
I don't get it, but everybody has their reason. So I would like that communication back of why maybe the reason is, I just, I can't swallow anything. I'm not feeling good.
I can't eat anything. I can't certainly not going to be able to swallow supplements. So I'm not going to buy any of those.
Well, then we could try to do switching around a test for some more liquid, a liquid approach or a powdered approach where you can make a smoothie.
I just would like that feedback so that we could be the best clinic for you.
So it is about you. So I don't want you to feel anybody to feel like they're putting us out. This is about you. We're here to serve you.
So we need the feedback. We need on a feedback of like, I just can't take all these. I need we get that feedback a lot.
And funny. It's sometimes we get that feedback. I don't want to take all these supplements anyway. I can cut back on supplements.
And I look at me everything you're taking. Like I ask all you guys and sometimes they're taking like 12 different supplements and I never even recommended.
So you guys got to look at this big picture too. And we just need to have that communication and have a discussion of what's going to be the best way for you to stay on a protocol that is going to be beneficial for you.
So keep that in mind as well.
Okay, next question. If I'm going to add fenben. So fenben is all to my protocol. Should I also add what you recommend that goes along with it?
That's what goes along with what's called the Joe Tippen's protocol, which is burberrying, curcumin.
I'm going to add a poppy, the full, the delta, total trade all e and CBD.
Generally speaking, yes, but it doesn't go back to the other question as if you feel like you're like overly abundant supplements and you can't take any more.
I don't want to tip you over, but it is generally believed that burberry and curcumin and vitamin E especially are synergistically working with fenben is all.
And you're going to get a better result when you take those together with the fenben is on now the CBD is on that margin.
It's not it's not recommended, but it's not as critical as the burberry and the curcumin and the e.
So, you know, if you were going to leave one off, I would leave off the CBD.
But generally speaking, the synergistic benefits of taking the burberry and curcumin and e together with the fenben is all the best approach generally speaking.
Okay, thank you for the new price. Absolutely.
I didn't know I had a day program. Well, everybody should have a day program in your folder.
You should have some day programs. Can you recommend ingredients for a cancer patient that is dairy free ingredients for what?
So, I'm very familiar with eating dairy free. We have a lot of people in our family that are dairy free for other reasons.
As far as a smoothie goes, okay, we never buy milk in our house, okay, so we don't have any cow's milk.
What do we use to add to a smoothie? Well, personally for me for my smoothie, I don't add any, quote, unquote, nut milk at all.
My wife does. She likes the coconut toasted coconut. I can't remember the brand. It comes in a plastic bottle.
It's toasted coconut and they have an organic one of those now.
And that's what we use for a substitute for milk in our house, like if we had a bowl of granola cereal or something.
I would use that toasted coconut. I think what is used to that? To me, it takes, we haven't had dairy cows milk in our house for a decade or so or more.
So my wife has been dairy free for a long time. So we would add that toasted coconut milk.
And I'm sorry, I can't, I can't tell you the brand name of it. Maybe somebody else can remember if they think of that.
If they use that same product that rings the bell.
But that's what we use as far as adding to a smoothie. Now, other things that you could add to a smoothie is coconut yogurt.
So there are all been yogurts out there. There's coconut yogurts out there.
You could use that in a smoothie. That would be something. Forage your brand makes and it makes a probably the best quality yogurt.
It's organic. Forage your brand if you could get that locally. That they may have a vanilla and they have a played yogurt brand. They don't have, I don't think they have like the berry or you don't have to add your own berries and stuff.
But that's probably the best quality yogurt. Thank you Stacey. It is cleaf of farms coconut milk. That's the one that is an organic coconut milk.
But toasted coconut and they have an organic almond milk. Both of those are good. Califa farms. They're getting to be a fairly big brand. Now you can get them in most grocery stores now.
Comes in a plastic bottle. And then forage your brand is they make a sour cream. That's actually pretty good. That's dairy free. They make a.
And I believe that's organic and they also make a the yogurts that are organic. That's my daughter feeds my granddaughter the sheet that my two granddaughters and her family just love that yogurt.
So that's what they use typically. I booked my appointment last week at former price, but my appointment still isn't till next week and I still we can refund you the difference on that.
Okay, any other questions that cleaf of farms also has a coffee creamer or what it's worth. There's lots of other coffee creamers that are dairy free out there too.
But I like that brand cleaf of farms.
Can I chat in? Can you hear me? Yes.
Okay, do you have any concern at all about all the gums in these non dairy milk and yogurt?
Not really. Because you really you're not eating that much of it.
And yes, there could there could be some negatives to different gums.
But a lot of them do act kind of like an indigestible fiber.
So you're not absorbing a lot of them. Now you can have sensitivities to different gums.
So if you use some of these products and you feel off at all in any way or got feels off or you have any type of symptoms, brain fog or anything like that.
There you can't have sensitivity. So the Syrex array 10 does test for different gums.
So if you have that thought process that you may have a sensitivity to that, then that's possible.
I understand everybody's everybody's a little bit different, but we buy a jug of that.
It's not like we're consuming a lot of it. But yeah, you do, there is a possibility of having a sensitivity to those that anything really anything you eat a lot of.
You could develop a sensitivity to so you do have to be aware of that.
Thank you. I have one more question for you. It's not related.
I am ready to retest for some of my my gut permeability issues. I took a test from a KBMO.
I don't know. I've heard of them and had some elevated Candida and LPS.
Yeah.
And do you have a different a test that you like to kind of monitor that ongoing link? Should I stick with the KBMO? Can you get that through Rupa for me?
Well, if you want to stick with the KBMO, you can just buy it and get it right off our store.
So we do add people in order that KBMO know I do like that test because it's less expensive than the Syrex.
But as far as quality testing, it's not as quality as the Syrex.
The Syrex tests for IGG and IGGA antibodies, which the KBMO doesn't.
And the Syrex tests for multiple different foods that are cooked and uncooked when the protein is changed in that particular food, which that gives a little bit more detail too.
As far as having lipopolysaccharides and evidence of Candida, when we do oat testing, that's organic acid testing on people.
In variable, people come up positive for Candida.
Now, one could argue that everybody has one could argue that majority of people have some level of Candida.
Syrex labs came up with a Candida vulnerability test that is a standalone test that tests whether what how bad a person's Candida is that's extremely accurate.
And I've had people run that test that showed positive of the oat test for Candida.
And then we run that test and it was negative.
So that's not uncommon what I've heard in the industry is that everybody's got some level of Candida, the majority people do.
But how much of that is really affecting them is there's only a small percentage of people that are in that category.
So does it mean that you shouldn't necessarily address the Candida?
I'm not saying that, but does everybody have to go on to Coprolic acid and that's your number one help for Candida?
I don't think so.
Should everybody be working on trying to heal their gut with different gut healing things, that would I think be a better approach than trying to quote unquote kill Candida because Candida is an opportunistic organism.
And if you heal good blue, the Candida is going to go back into balance. Remember Candida is is part of your normal flora as well.
It's just what it's out of balance. It's like H. Pylora. H. Pylora is actually part of your normal flora, but it's what it's out of balance that it becomes a problem.
Now, label boy saccharides are a little bit different. If you're positive with label polysaccharides, that is suggestive of bacteria in the gut that were gram negative bacteria that then can damage the gut wall even farther.
And you could get not only so typically what's thought about what leaky gut is the cells themselves are separated.
So the tight junctions of the cells the tightness each cell up to each other is called the tight junction that tight junction is loosened and then you are absorbing things that you should never absorb.
Peptides of proteins that should never have gotten through because the cells are somewhat separated and peptides can get through that separation and get into the gut cavity and get into the bloodstream.
If that's the case that's typically what's thought about with leaky gut, but if you have label polysaccharides presence, they can actually damage the cell wall itself of the endothelial cell, epithelial cells that line the gut.
And if you have damage of that cell wall, then you have things that are literally going through the cell that are getting into the bloodstream.
So that's even further damage of the gut.
So again, what do you do if you have lipopolysaccharides, do you try to keel it or bind the lipopolysaccharides to get rid of them? No, you're dealing with trying to heal the gut.
Okay, so you're doing gut healing procedures, things like slippery elmen and deglycerized licorice and marshmallow and fiber and all these different things.
And then you're also looking at what could have been a production factor of lipopolysaccharides could have been just an infection that a person had.
But it's quite often, you have to, if it's a chronic thing, you look at H. Pylori or you look at Lyme disease.
So those are your, the number one cause of increased lipopolysaccharides is Lyme disease, because Burelia spits out a ton of lipopolysaccharides.
H. Pylori does as well, but more on a chronic basis, it's not going to be as higher levels.
But any lipopolysaccharides can damage epithelial cells, can damage endothelial cells, those are the cells that lie in your arteries, and can damage blood brain barrier cells, the astrocytes.
So the astrocytes make up your blood brain barrier, and the astrocytes can be damaged by lipopolysaccharides.
So an adult is supposed to have an intact blood brain barrier, and with that brain stuff, then we're getting things, more things crossing the blood brain barrier causing microglial primate and causing, you know, just overall brain inflammation and then possibly antibodies to neural tissue.
So how do you ultimately address this? Well, you're going back to trying to heal, keeping a gut healing protocol.
Well, part of a gut healing protocol is to make sure you're not eating foods that are inflammatory to you.
And the most common things are going to be dairy and gluten, eggs are not so much eggs, so a and then testing for, you know, why possibly eating hidden foods that are inflammatory if you're having problems, you test for those.
So, you know, on a less expensive test to the KBMO, on a more accurate test to it a Syrex 10, but there's another test got Zuber tested when they first came out, they were less expensive, but they're both same prices as the Syrex test now.
So I think Syrex is, Syrex is my preferred test, I think it's the most accurate.
I hope that helps next question. What is the best supplement available for cold or bacterial infection, drainage, coughing, sinus issues with ear pain, but tested negative for flu, COVID and strength?
First of all, I don't think anybody should be doing the COVID test, okay, not accurate.
It shouldn't be running, it shouldn't be doing testing for COVID. If you got this crud that's blown going around that I had a couple weeks ago, then what should you be taking?
Why do the things that you're on for cancer will be helpful for these things as well, but in general, if it's a bacterial infection, you think of garlic, oregano oil,
a straggolus, those are all good for bacterial infections, they're also good for viral infections, vitamin C with zinc.
Of course, you don't want vitamin C if you have cancer, but taking short-term to deal with an infection, it's nothing wrong with that.
Your aloevia immune, which is a polysaccharide, your other mushrooms are polysaccharides, they're good for immune stimulation, doing gargolene with salt water can be good.
Using the garlic oil eardrops can be good, using holyopasts for lymph drainage, we have some from professional formulas that are really good.
What's a called immune stem by herb farm is an echinacea straggolus and stuff product.
It's a liquid herbal that tastes pretty gross, but taking drops under your tongue of that throughout the day is really good.
There's a ton of different herbal stimulants that are all safe to take for cancer.
If you have an autoimmune disease, all those things that I just mentioned can actually flare an autoimmune disease, but taking a very short term to deal with a sickness is typically okay to deal with.
Those immune stimulants long-term with an autoimmune disease because it can make that worse.
So people with cancer and a serious autoimmune disease are in a catch-22 on waste, and that's more difficult to try to kill the cancer.
You're also trying not to have this huge colitis flare or something, so it's balancing that out.
How about coming in for a sore throat? I have a great success with onion, poultice, over your throat, bind with a scarf overnight.
That's a good choice. So there's a lot of things like that.
There's, we have some, we got a ton of stuff in our store.
I would accept to go down and walk through it to think of some of the products that you could take for trying to build up your immune system when you're dealing with this virus or bacterial infection or whatever it is.
But one of the best things you guys have, all of you in your house, is a knife machine.
So, run the cold and flu and the modia programs and run those programs.
So, currently, we only have one knife in our house after I felt like I was recovered even though I still kind of lost my voice.
From this stay a couple of weeks ago, my wife attends to get things go to her lungs because she's damaged her lungs when she was younger with the modia.
So, I brought the knife up and was running a pneumonia blaster bacterial strat program for her because I think this thing going around has some people may have a bacterial component and several different viral components.
So, definitely run on the virus program on your wife. That would be helpful. Any other questions?
All right. Well, thanks for being on today, everybody.
We will.
I'll cook it. Oh, wait, next.
Another else, but you'll see another member site next week.
Next week, we will not have a zoom call. I'm going to be out of town next week.
So, no zoom call next week. I'll put it up on the member site so everybody knows.
All right, everybody. Have a blessed week.
And a great night tonight. Bye-bye.